our old friend candace owens is the host
of candace she joins us now kenneth
thanks so much
for coming on so joe biden's party
has i mean they didn't create crime
crime is a feature of human nature but
they have
made possible this terrifying jump in
crime rates and murder rates
and now they're going to quote solve the
problem
what are the chances their solutions
make them more powerful
100 percent the chances are 100 percent
of the solutions are going to
make them more powerful look i'll say it
i'll spell it out plainly the united
states government at this point is
engaged in criminality there's really no
other way to say it they know exactly
what they're doing uh they're using
black people and racism as pawns to
distract people from what's actually
going on which is
our government is it has increased its
power exponentially
over the last two years i mean covet 19
they've extended their powers into
telling you when you can open your
businesses
uh when you can breathe literally when
you can breathe
right quote 19 among other things will
be remembered as one of the greatest
wealth transfers
of the government to itself right taking
our tax payer dollars
and and giving themselves trillions upon
trillions you bring up lori lightfoot
this is a woman who just decided that
she's going to use 19 funds she's going
to transfer 10 million of those dollars
tucker
um to explore a public health crisis
that is racism
what does it even mean i'll tell you
what it means it means that there's
going to be more government right
they're going to employ more people
government is going to get more power
because they're going to keep this issue
going and that is exactly why if you're
wondering why they're talking about
juneteenth you can file that under
critical race theory you can file that
under the 1619 project
all of these things are meant to
distract from us taking a look at where
everything bad that is happening in our
country right now is coming from
and that is the united states government
being controlled by democrats who seek
nothing more
than to enrich and empower themselves
man that was about the crispest
summation i've heard in a long time of a
very complex issue and every word of it
true
in my view kenneth owens thanks so much
for coming on tonight thank you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else